les français multiplient les actes de
solidarité pendant le continent avant le
coït 19
il avait déjà fait preuve d'entr'aide
face à des crises en 1954 l'abbé pierre
lançait un appel pour aider les sans
abri durant l'hiver mais le soir les
paquets de couvertures de vêtements
affluer et je ne sont pas seulement des
riches qui ont donné quelque chose
la solidarité était aussi présente en
1959 après la catastrophe du barrage de
malpasset dans le bar ni de tous les
coins de france de l'étranger arrive des
camions des vivres du matériel à la
mairie le service de santé s'emploie à
vacciner toute la population tous ces
milliers d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
qui ont retrouvé le chemin de l'espoir
en 1978 le pétrolier amoco cadiz
s'échouer sur les côtes bretonnes
400 km de côtes souillées par la marée
noire pour nettoyer cents lycéens
étaient venus prêter main forte
puisque tu comptes faire aider au
maximum en acide pétrole les loisirs en
1988 la jeunesse était encore au rendez
vous alors que nîmes venait de subir des
inondations meurtrières
les enfants des cévennes offraient leurs
services aux habitants sinistrés bien
besoin de manger que nous on en a ce
serait pas mal de distribuer tout le
monde lors de la tempête de 1999
la solidarité passer par la radio locale
il y avait presque plus d'offres
d'hébergement que de demandes
d'hébergement parce que probablement on
n'ose pas immédiatement dire voulez-vous
me recueillir chez vous il y avait des
gens spontanément qui a appelé en disant
écoutez je peut loger trois personnes à
la maison face à l'épidémie de covile 19
le personnel médical appellent à la
solidarité
les dons de masques se multiplient pour
tenter de pallier la pénurie
[Musique]